see for the first time out because both  teams need the time out as we get Dwyane  Wade up off the bench and the crowd  giving him his props  and here is this Stu says Dwyane Wade  and we every time and I believe Toyota  let's go places  ladies Adam an honor of Dwayne Wade's  final trip to Staples Center this  evening to take off the Lakers turned  your attention to the video board as we  say thank you and pay tribute to one of  the top players of the century  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  what up minute  to meet you the greatest unselfish  superstar that's ever played in this  game  Lakers basketballs being brought to you  by spider-man into the split for Dwayne  Wade  there's his wife he just gave birth to  their beautiful baby daughter few weeks  ago in fact that's why weight did not  play in the last game he was on  paternity leave  in fact the baby hasn't even been back  to Miami